okay our developing story for you here
on the newsour there is an ongoing
escalation in the situation violence in
the Beller Russian Capital Minsk the
internet was shut down in the last 90
minutes or so the police are saying
they've detained at least 250
demonstrators who were gathering for
another protest in
Minsk they're standing by their demands
that President Alexander lukashenka's
resignation ever since he was declared
the winner of last month's disputed
election that's what they want they want
him to go critics say the vote was
rigged well than 10,000 women defied a
government Crackdown to Rally in the
city on Saturday for the 35th
consecutive day our correspondent St
vson is in the thick of it we will try
and establish Communications with her
clearly we have no internet link
telephone lines are maybe a bit
questionable as well we will go to set
vson just as soon as we establish comms
with her we'll stay with these latest
pictures we'll also now talk to our
correspondent in Moscow that's
alexandera what kind of reception do we
think Mr lucenko will receive when he
arrives in Russia to meet Mr
Putin well you see the relationship
between these two between the
belarussian president Alexander lenko
and Russian one Vladimir Putin has never
been an easy one it was a a complex
relationship of love and hate where
lenko was before these elections and
before he started having so such big
problems in his own country uh he was
sort of uh trying to uh play an upper
hand sometimes winning it sometimes
losing it so uh because he got this so
much needed support from uh Russia and
from its President Vladimir Putin it is
clearly who has the upper hand is this
negotiations now he got support Russia
is one of the few countries that
recognized him as the winner of the
disputed elections and Russia is clearly
stating that yes he is the president and
this is the matter uh that is internal
matter of what is happening in Bas and
that it is not the oppositional council
members the ones that should anyone talk
to actually they're saying that there is
countries meddling in these elections
and warning everybody off from that uh
President Putin even said that there is
a reserve unit prepared if things get
really out of control reserve unit here
in Russia that will be sent as a help to
to uh the B Russia if needed if certain
red lines are crossed so what we do
expect tomorrow is that these are going
to be uh negotiations that in which uh
the upper hand will be uh and and the
cards will be in the hands of uh Putin
now Russia has been pushing for
finalizing or wrapping it up this the
organization called Union State between
Russia and B Bas to which lukashenko was
quite resistant to to finalizing it uh
and they're doing that now we could hear
this uh organization mentioned numerous
uh times saying that uh they are
supposed to protect each other uh the
Constitution Democratic rights and so
forth and uh so on so it is expected by
some analysts here that Russia might be
uh pushing now that it has the
opportunity to do so uh for uh some sort
of a integration with Bellas though here
they're denying a use of such word or a
merg we could hear but in kremin they're
saying no it's not about that these are
going to stay to Sovereign countries uh
whatever whatever happens okay we'll
leave it there Alexandra sanovich Goa
for the moment Alexandra thank you very
much we have established Communications
with alero's correspondent step Bon who
what 15 20 minutes ago she was in the
middle of what was going on not what
you're looking at right now she was with
the demonstrators going to that Central
Point in Minsk for the protest step just
take us through what's happening
I'm here in the middle of uh thousands
of protesters right now marching towards
one of lukashenka's residences uh We've
passed several areas with uh lots of
police and military on guard but because
this is such a large group it's very
hard to uh estimate how many people are
here but it's uh probably tens of
thousands so police and military have
left this uh group alone uh despite the
fact that in the beginning of this
rally hundreds were detained snatched
from the streets driven up in a by
masked man and I'm actually walking here
towards a group of women they're also
wearing these the same masks as these
policemen do just to make uh a protest
about it telling the people hear that
this is like cruel that uh this is not
part of how bellarus could be
people should not be in fear and uh
being
intimidated being snatched off the
street in broad daylight just for
walking on the streets maybe possibly
carrying a flag so people are angry but
the the mood is very upbeat I have to
say there's a lot of music and people
are very impressed by the fact that
despite these the tensions and the
repression we've seen in the last week
that they still manag together they're
now singing we will win we will survive
we will overcome so this is the mood and
there's also Children Here older people
people from literally all walks of life
are gathering here now as you were uh
finishing off that answer there step we
cut some pictures of a young female
demonstrator being taken away and piled
into the back of what looks like oh
pardon me I thought she was going to be
put into the side of the back of a a
blue VW van there but she's actually
being taken further away from the
vantage point of the camera as you were
uh explaining what was going on there
step we were looking at a a shot clearly
taken by uh somebody on a cell phone a
mobile telephone looking down at this
huge arching turning road with several
thousand people on its way I'm going to
assume step that you're in amongst all
the people we've now racked the pictures
we're looking at those heading towards
one of Mr lukashenka's residen is there
in Minsk if he's in that building and
they know he's in the building is there
potential there for that to become not
just a protest but a confrontation and a
flasho that's definitely something he's
been very worried about uh the Second
Sunday when protest was also heading
headed towards his residence at the at
the palace here he actually showed up in
a body armor carrying a Kalashnikov and
he was uh riding in a helicopter above
the crowd and uh I've spoken to experts
here analysts who have been following uh
his career and also been writing a
biography about him and they said that
uh that was definitely a sign of fear so
he's very worried of course that this uh
Crow will uh will go for him but so far
and they has been stressing this over
and over again their means are peaceful
never been any real violence done by
these protesters except from what I saw
throwing some plastic bottles there have
not been any attempts to really turn
this movement into a violent one because
they know very well that if that happens
that that's exactly what lukashenka and
also Russia might be waiting for and
that's the sign for them to interfere
actually uh across the come here with
the tro
because sorry there's a lot of noise
around me but Putin has already
announced that he has a contingent of
troops ready on the other side of the
borders to come any moment this
situation is out of control so everyone
is very aware of that risk and they keep
it as peaceful as possible at the moment
I'm just Sur
people carrying Flags carrying children
clapping their hands singing songs
so that's the mood right now do those
demonstrators that you're marching with
well you're not marching with them step
you're you're reporting on their protest
do they know The Internet's been
cut the internet is totally cut that's
why I'm speaking to you on the phone and
the reason is of course because these
demonstrations have been directed by
social media there are telegram channels
that are posting information for all
these protesters where they know they
can gather and that's why the
authorities have been blocking the
internet every Sunday to make sure that
they're not gathering together but uh
they still manag to do so
obviously we are now reporting here on
this channel step that the the internet
provider was asked by the government to
shut down the internet we don't know how
long for but is there an expectation
there that you know it's autocracy 101
isn't it if you want to make sure or try
to make sure that word doesn't get out
of the country about what you're doing
or what you're about to do you shut down
internet But the irony is somebody will
always spend the money on 4G or 5G and
then reporters like yourself you're
there talking to us on an oldfashioned
telephone exactly there's always a way
way out and that's also how this
telegram channel is operating they manag
to evade these internet uh blockades for
some reason so that's why you can still
see footage coming in video material
that's actually filmed by uh by citizens
who have been sending this uh footage to
uh other people so it can be spread
around so it's very hard to uh to block
all this because of course this is the
21st century and Lenka has been accused
of living in the past that his ideas
were all outdated that he still has this
old Soviet mentality and that the
economy in the country is also still run
in a Soviet style that's not suitable
for this this time anymore and that's
exactly why these people here they want
a different future for the children
which is more modern and has more
opportunities okay step do stay close uh
thanks very much for getting us up to
date on what's going on there if you're
just joining us here on the newsour what
you're looking at are a mish mash of the
latest pictures coming to us out of the
belarussian capital Minsk you can see
there the security forces have been
deployed to either try to cattle away
from the main thrust of the protest and
the protesters as they make their way in
their thousands to one of the
presidential compounds the president of
course being Alexander lukashenka he
says he won the election four or five
weeks ago the protesters say no you
didn't they say it was rigged was it
free and fair impossible to know because
as we've been reporting again over the
past four or five weeks um neutral
election observers in certain situations
at certain times in the runup to the
vote and on the day of the vote were not
given proper access to that vote so we
have not had an authoritative
trustworthy statement from anyone who
you would trust to say yes the election
was free and fair they want him to go
they are Marching In Their thousands now
uh towards one of his residencies and a
step Von was saying there one of the
issues is they know Mr lukashenka knows
that he is not looking forward to that
situation to put it mildly where he's in
his residence if he's in the building
that they are walking towards uh and
have thousands or tens of thousands of
protesters outside because both sides
are digging in here let's stay with the
latest pictures and bring
uh Peter zmeev he's joining us on Skype
from Kiev in Ukraine now he is the
executive director of the Eurasia
democracy
initiative welcome to the news house sir
just take me through your reaction to
what we're seeing happening on the
streets of
Minsk well uh we're seeing a culmination
of uh I would say what three four three
weeks actually a month of a truly
popular Uprising that has as its game as
its aim as its sole aim the aler of a
man who has ruled this country with a
iron fist for a quarter of a century uh
the the people that are out on the
streets have not been protesting against
the Kremlin they have not been appealing
to any European values uh and which is
distinguishing this particular
Revolution we're witnessing from that
that happened in Ukraine uh 6 years ago
the one goal the protesters have is to
get rid of the guy and they're doing it
in a spectacularly Democratic fashion
with no single leader with the
leadership dispersed and with a truly
kind of popular um it's a true popular
Uprising the likes of which Belarus has
never witnessed why is it though you
know we're four or five weeks into this
process now why is it though no side is
either winning or no side is on the
other hand of that debate giving in to
the other no one seems to be able to
deal a killer blow here on the part of
either the president or the
demonstrators well it's a very good
question and uh on the part of
lukashenka we're seeing that uh he is
able to hold on just enough uh simply
because he has re retained the Loyalty
of his security uh services that has not
wavered with few exceptions the big uh
unknown remains Vladimir Putin who has
sent contradictory signals but is yet
from what we have been able to see
unwilling to contemplate a victory by a
street protest which will create a very
unpleasant precedent for Russia and for
Putin's uh rule when it comes to the
protesters I think we're witnessing
truly that the belar Russians are
finally waking up after uh their 70
years of the Soviet Rule and 25 years of
this guy they are willing to shake off
their fear but for right now their
protest has been uh
peaceful and the big debate is whether
they will uh you know uh consider taking
a militant action against lukashenka and
there are indications now that certain
uh uh defense brigades as they're called
are being formed so before long we may
uh see uh an a an armed uh Uprising and
in that I mean in that situation all
bets are off and luceno is counting on
Putin uh introducing uh troops to quell
the uprising okay forgive me if I if I'm
sounding about OCD about this Peter but
are you saying an armed Uprising because
the security
services basically stage a coup or and
they start fighting
with their own weapons alongside the
protesters are you saying that's a
possibility
here I I'm saying the protesters
themselves are arming whether it be
moletto cocktails sticks Stones uh you
know light weapons uh we are going to be
seeing some of that simply because there
is that um sort of standoff that's not
moving either here no there as you
mentioned uh and uh as is often the case
in such situ situations these things
have a tendency of being uh of turning
violent you know and I there's also a
scenario you cannot discount and that
scenario would have Russian or
lukashenka uh provocators uh uh sort of
uh trying to come across as protesters
uh and inciting violence so that
lukashenka uh has an excuse to welcome
Russian tanks uh in order to quell that
prising but once again we we are not
certain as to what Vladimir Putin's
moves will be I'm not so sure he's is
going to be willing to support a very
unpopular president so he just like
anyone any of us experts who are now
guessing what's going to happen next I
will guarantee you Putin himself is
daily calculating the odds of this or
that move on his part he does not know
what's going to happen himself the
situation is uh very unpredictable and
uh bustable at the same time and also
you cannot of course discount the
possibility of a coup that you mentioned
but for right now we are not seeing
those signs yet okay Peter zmeev uh in
Kiev in Ukraine great to get your
Insight on this Peter we'll talk to you
again I'm sure in the future for the
meantime thank you very much joining us
on the phone out of Minsk is yaroslav
romanuk he's formerly a Bellar Russian
presidential candidate uh Mr romanchuk
welcome to the NewsHour here here on
aler when you see the pictures my
pleasure to be with you thank you sir
when you see the pictures we're
broadcasting when you see thousands of
people demonstrating again for Mr Lucas
shenka to go when we see young old men
and women being bundled to the ground
and bundled into the backs of Vans again
when we see hundreds of women peacefully
demonstrating once a week again what
goes through your mind at that point
I'm just back from another demonstration
and uh that's Joy that's happiness that
determination to get rid of the
dictatorship uh that's the peaceful and
orderly nature I do not see that it
would turn violent unless the
authorities uh turn into using weapons
instead of just watching and uh grabbing
uh demonstrators yesterday we had over
about 300 persons w detained by police
today I think that the demonstrators
began with detentions so the authorities
are using these tactics to start to
detain people before and right after if
people like do not not form the crowd of
course everybody uh is waiting for
tomorrow's meeting between Putin and
lukashenka uh Putin definitely is at a
crossroad because he definitely would uh
use uh the assistance the he would Aid l
in the military and paramilitary way but
that would uh infuriate belarusians and
that would add definitely more um
resistance to Russian uh aggression and
Putin would be called aggressor
alongside with wenka the kremin doesn't
want it to happen that's why it wants uh
lukashenka to somehow start a dialogue
but uh lukashenka is still adamant and
he believed that he could go on without
uh any dialogue and he would reappoint
himself as uh for the presidency once
again so that's a deadlock but the
determination of of the people of
barians is not dying out and uh I was in
groda yesterday the same kind of spirit
I was in breast week ago the same kind
of spirit so it's not only Minsk it's
the whole country is against the regime
and it's I think it's a matter of time
before Lenka has to uh give up and start
a negotiation on the transition of power
okay lots to unpack with the what you've
just been saying to us there Mr romanuk
let's talk about that meeting tomorrow
first off as we uh continue breaking
down these latest pictures out of Minsk
so Mr lukashenko walks into a handshake
photo up conversation with Vladimir
Putin How does that conversation
go uh they are not on funly terms to put
it mly uh Lenka campaigned for a long
time against the Kremlin against the
Putin accus in Russia of trying to uh
have a political merger uh between
Russia and Belarus and uh essentially it
was lukashenka who broke Putin's plan to
uh stay in power for another 16 years I
mean pu had to Stage this Con
constitutional referendum so uh the uh
relations between barus and Russia on
the lowest possible level in trade terms
in integration terms so there is uh like
cold animosity or cold friendship uh
between them but at the same time there
is a like different points of view in
Russia on what to do generals are uh
supporting lukashenka because they've
been working with him for a long time uh
people who do Economic Policy definitely
don't like to have any military any
intervention into B realizing that Lenka
is the guy who would uh never keep his
word his promise
okay Mr ruk I'm going to interrupt you
for a second sir for which I apologize
but I do just want to get to one final
brief point the protesters are saying
Lenka is going to go you're saying
lukashenka is going to go Mr Putin may
say to him uh Mr Lenka you've got to go
what is it about Mr lukashenka that
makes him so supremely unself-aware of
how other people see
him the major factor is that he could
not have failed to resist evil and he is
associated with evil himself that's the
fundamental point that makes everybody
believe that he must
go oh and I think we've lost the line
there from
Minsk yes we have okay we were talking
there to yaroslav romanuk a former
belarussian presidential candidate
apologies for that you know live
television these things happen uh we'll
go back to him if we can but we did
manage to get a good sense of what his
take is on the latest situation there
you can see it unfolding pretty much in
real time thousands perhaps tens of
thousands of people are making their way
towards one of Alexander lukashenka's
presidential residencies in the middle
of Minsk is he inside the building we
don't know is he anticipating this kind
of protest yes very probably uh the
internet has been cut did he issue a
direct order to have the internet uh
pulled the plug on it yes he probably
did because the internet provider has
confirmed uh to various news agency and
news suppliers that they were asked by
uh the belarussian government to make
sure that the internet was not working
but as is the way with modern technology
we are able to get you the latest
pictures and correspondents and analysts
on the ground and also in Russia and in
Ukraine we will go back to that evolving
story for you just as soon as we
can